all right let's get to audience emails
the mailbag for the week you can email
info davidpackman.com there are some
very aggressive ones this week and I
will let you know sometimes a tweet will
be used sometimes a YouTube comment
might be included or a Facebook comment
or whatever the case may be we start
today with Donnie via Facebook who and
I'm gonna try to do my best reading of
this that I can Donnie had an opinion
and wrote in shortly after the uh
midterm election and said suffer from
TDS much you pedo supporting libtard
goof go sniff a little kid like your
potato in Chief pedo Joe then go smoke
crack with Hunter and F some hookers you
and you is misspelled almost every time
effing libtard loser goof they then got
our Standard Auto response that you know
I'm not going to be writing them back
and then they wrote back get effed so
someone very much struggling with uh
emotions and that type of thing I do
often wonder like what type of job could
this person have could this be your
accountant for example where you go in
and they go listen uh I would advise you
to take the full 179
depreciation on your new 6 000 pound
vehicle excuse me a second you pedo
sniffing bet sorry I'm just writing a
message go get a
are these people our doctors our
accountants Etc uh or not just a
question I don't know I never know the
answer next message is another person on
teaching transgender this person wrote
in and said You Lie when you say they
don't teach about trans it happened to
my son and daughter at a young age you
POS
who can't Define woman I don't know if
that's a question or a statement you
looked like such a loser on Michael
Knowles show laughable how smug of a
liberal you looked like and what's wrong
with singing our national anthem leave
then That's a classic you don't like it
leave it's progressives like you who
change everything good in this country I
know it's like we have weekends now and
we have minimum standards for health
insurance and minimum standards for
Education
give me a break dude you're all sick and
yes I just paid 550 for gas and our
store said they were late getting
turkeys what guy talks about cooking a
beautiful chicken C you change
Traditions I I guilty is charged okay
for me
spending what is it six hours
with a turkey in the oven and then you
get it out and the dark meat is just
it's just not that good guys let's not
pretend like turkey's that great okay
and then you've got the breast and
you're slicing it and it's enormous and
your checking is it done or not
I say get yourself a couple of just
nicely sized pasture-raised organic
chickens beautifully crispy skin takes
45 to 75 minutes in the oven everybody's
happy it's just better I'm not telling
you to change your tradition I'm just
telling you it's better and by the way
plenty of turkeys at every grocery store
I've been going to okay Casey wrote In
Casey says David seeing that many of
Trump's hand-picked candidates
underperformed and a clear split in the
Republican party is about to materialize
do you think it's at all likely Trump
runs as an independent in 24. if the
Republican party and media turn against
him what do you think would happen if he
just took his base with him and started
his own party I doubt he'll do it or
that it would occur to him but it's
something I could see him doing if
nothing else out of pure narcissism I
think that that's actually the critical
part of this question
if Trump actually cared about the
Republican party we would all be saying
he would never do that he would never
run as an independent because it would
almost ensure even if he just brought
over 10 percent of the Republican vote
15 some small relatively small amount he
guarantees Democrats win but that's if
Trump cared about the Democratic the
Republican Party
Trump doesn't care
about the Republican Party
that's the reality and therefore I do
think it's possible that Trump might run
as an independent out of desperation out
of humiliation if indeed DeSantis just
outright defeats him in a primary I hope
it happens I think it would be a great
thing for the country in that it would
hurt both Trump and whoever is the
eventual Republican nominee I love it we
should encourage Trump to do it Ellen
Rhoden
uh about Maga as a mental illness this
is interesting Ellen says hey David a
few times on your show you've wondered
aloud about the cause of the Maga
condition you expressed concern that you
might be overstepping by calling out
their behavior if it's mental illness
that's causing it I think it's good
you're considering that it shows your
empathy but I also suspect you believe
as I do that they're caught their causes
are multiple and nuanced and you're
going to keep doing it because the
bottom line is we can't become apathetic
towards the movement I think the way you
handle them is fine very little mocking
there which is pretty impressive yeah
when we say
is Maga a mental illness in some of
those people I'm not laughing at it I
think we need to deal with mental
illness in this country if we determine
I mean listen
I want undiagnosed and untreated mental
illness to be diagnosed and to be
treated
that whatever it is and if that mental
illness is part of why someone Falls for
Maga delusion
it's good to treat it both because it's
better to help people when they're
struggling with mental illness and it
might prevent us from going down this
insane path of trumpism once again so I
appreciate Ellen's comment very much
Eric Rhoden are people like Mike Lindell
and Herschel Walker part of the Maga
grift or victims of it this is another
interesting perspective from Eric Eric
says hey David do you think people like
Mike Lindell and Herschel Walker are
knowingly part of the Maga grift or were
they victims of it what I mean is do
these mid-level front men know it's all
a grift or are they just patsies being
exploited due to their celebrity status
and psychological vulnerability for
example
I don't think Herschel Walker woke up
one morning and decided running for the
U.S Senate is the next logical step in
his professional and personal life
obviously somebody approached him with
the idea likewise Mike pillow is
destroying himself financially and seems
to be used by other people as a pawn and
ATM machine for I guess their own profit
and ambition the reason I ask this is
well we can't change the minds of Mega
followers directly it would be great if
we could find a way to wake up these
linchpin people to reality
yeah I uh I don't know the answer to
that Mike pillow seems like a True
Believer Herschel Walker kind of seems
like he might have been grifted in with
appeals to his narcissism and ego and
that's what you have to understand
ego is a common thing okay if you have a
show like mine on some fundamental level
you think your opinions are interesting
enough for other people to listen to
them rather than to just make their own
show right so like can it be denied that
on some level I must think well I don't
know what I have to say is at least
interesting enough that I should make a
show with elected officials this is
significantly bigger and we've looked at
traits of narcissism Etc and
what happens with a lot of these people
is they become convinced like Trump did
and apparently like Herschel Walker that
they're somehow needed by the country
that they're doing some great thing and
um I wonder whether at this point it's
too late for Herschel Walker to be
talked out of that he may soon be gone
if we do our job in uh in the state of
Georgia and uh we'll get back to that in
a moment interesting uh email from
Julian Julian says interesting subreddit
drama David an interesting segment for
the bonus show or something could be
reading replies on the conservative
subreddit very interesting to see what
some of them are saying about Trump
imagine he runs as an independent in 24
and splits the vote I recommend checking
this out as it reminds me of the betting
market segments in terms of indication
of conservative opinion yeah if you
check out the conservative subreddit
like reddit.com R conservative
you will find that there is a not
insignificant portion that is mad at
Trump
and ready to abandon Donald Trump now
what if anything it tells us about 24 I
think it's just way too early but it's
interesting let's deal with the December
runoff first Kerry wrote In
and said please come to Georgia
we need you
I am figuring out Carrie
how can I get as involved as possible in
Georgia given that I don't think I can
make it down there in the next few weeks
and we're going to be doing a bunch of
stuff critically important to get 51
rather than 50. imagine a supposed Red
Wave
in which Democrats gain a seat in the
Senate I mean that's just that's amazing
Brian Rhoden Brian has sad news and says
you lost a daily listener I'm sure you
don't care but I actually loved your
show prior to the last few days with all
your negativity which never happened
sorry need more positive in my life I
know you want to keep it real but holy
cow your negativity was the worst I'm
switching to Mighty Midas as I watched
them as well and they were dead on right
with all their content and even head on
a guest that nailed the election that
Fox News had made fun of their guest was
100 percent right
listen
I was
as honest as possible
in the lead up to the midterm
I said the momentum had shifted to
Republicans and that is indeed the case
what over the summer was looking like a
much bigger Democratic victory in the
Senate came down to just one or two
seats a lot of these races ended up way
closer look at fetterman odds way closer
than it was supposed to be in July I
correctly told you the momentum is going
to the Republicans and I said
the specific numbers may be skewed
because of right-wing polls that are
being included in the averages
I was very upfront
and the most important thing I said
was we're so close
that the polling no longer matters it's
about voting oh fetterman's up three or
down two doesn't matter
if we are allowed to vote in
Pennsylvania we vote in Pennsylvania
um so yes Brian is done with this show
because of that because of something I
guess that I don't really understand I
do appreciate all the very nice messages
I got from people saying David I think
you struck the right balance between
this is the polling here are the
limitations here's what might be going
on and making sure that everybody votes
that was the critical uh um message and
enough people did including 18 to 29
year olds that the Red Wave ended up
being potentially a Ripple uh we have a
great bonus show for you today sign up
at joinpakman.com and of course we will
be back Monday with much much much more